[Music]  the leftist project for centuries has  sought to perfect human nature and each  social experiment to that end has failed  and left varying degrees of misery in  its wake  scientific experiments to achieve that  goal may prove more effective but by no  means any more desirable Winston  Churchill warned of another scheme to  craft the master race that we might sink  into the abyss of a new Dark Age made  more sinister and perhaps more  protracted by the lights of perverted  science perhaps we should take a moment  to unfurl philosophy and culture before  we embrace a science with the potential  to destroy our humanity itself I'm  Michael Knowles this is Michael Nolt  show no more shows this week tune back  in Monday and we'll see you then  [Music]  you  [Music]